thank you madam chair school board
members
superintendent and ladies and
gentlemen uh to the agenda item 9.01 a I
would like to thank the superintendent
for her leadership finally listening to
the community in putting together an
order for guidelines of guest speakers
into the school
district I think uh Madame chair needs
to follow that leadership in a school
board meeting in the very near future
and ensuring that it becomes policy but
this is a very good
start later I will talk about a specific
organization in general comments so I'll
Reserve those comments until then thank
you thank you for um this is actually
not pertaining to guest speakers it's
pertaining to
um yes ma'am that's care is the same
same issue care is the same issue thank
you good afternoon school board members
my name is Bonnie Bonnie Reynolds and I
am a member of the education Coalition
here are my questions and thoughts
directed to the school board members who
voted against the public Workshop
regarding the issue of care in our
Hillsboro County Public
Schools why why would you allow care a
known terrorist organization the ability
to have access to our children in our
schools terrorism is a way is a major
concern in America today and it has
changed our lives ADV in a variety of
ways feeling and knowing its threat at a
local level is not something that we can
take lightly or casually dismiss just as
our nation has taken steps to establish
policies for the security of its people
so too it's our time to act and Rise why
why would you fail to act upon voices of
concerned we are not and we have no
intention of accusing or holding
negligent or disrespecting any County
educator or this Administration we are
simply and respectfully asking this
question
now why do you ignore the facts
presented silence legitimate concern and
vote against a public hearing to
establish a policy to ensure our
children's
protection why would you not Institute a
policy to safeguard our students
guaranteeing no representative of any
organization has has been linked to
terrorism by the federal government or
is ever invited into a Hillsboro County
classroom as well spoken as in previous
board meetings by one m I quote anywhere
we can tighten up protection for our
students is important why why then would
you not Unite with light minds and
together proceed forward with a policy
to make this happen thank
you all those issues that are coming to
the far and that are of concern this is
your chance if you wish to speak okay
Philip renolds
go ahead all right thank you hi um my
name is Philip Reynolds I'm currently a
high school student in Hillsboro County
um just on the issues of care and um the
whole organization I just like to read
some quotes of some of the leaders in
the group and members um jar sadala
bedran he's a member he said Hamas and
hezb are comenting acts of defense
against the israels the only weapons
that we have to are to strap bombs to
bodies and do whatever damage we can
that I'm I'm sorry that just doesn't
sound very peaceful uh and and a good
thing to bring into a classroom with
people like that in the group parvez AED
said that Hamas and hezbo should be part
of the political process I I don't think
so considering they're a terrorist
organization they really probably
shouldn't be in our education um Randall
Todd Royer was their civil rights
coordinator and he was sentenced to 20
years in prison for his activities
within the Virginia Jihad
Network um ahed beier the president of K
Tampa United voice for America said that
we want the government to fear
us AA Ahmed Ali said Hamas is not a
terrorist organization he's executive
director for care Florida um and I I'm
sorry the last I checked I think Hamas
is a terrorist organization and hmaf
pansan said that the false gods of this
Society are Jesus democracy and the Bill
of Rights um excuse me but that's what
this country was founded on I don't
think my closing I just like to mention
that I as a student feel strongly that
it is not safe to allow care into our
classrooms considering the type of
leadership they have and who they
associated with thank you that's right
[Applause]
Charles
Keller Charles
Keller Madam chair and Lord members I
thank you for this opportunity to have
my say on this I'm an ordained American
Baptist minister in hospital chaplain B
and um fire department chapl I was AOL
child in suburban Chicago when our
nation due to fear engendered by World
War II incarcerated thousands of
Japanese citizens I eventually came to
know one of these victims Reverend Jitsu
maawa was a pastor of the Japanese
Baptist Church in Chicago he and his
family along with members of his
congregation were placed in detention
camps later he became the leader of the
evangelism work of the American Baptist
Churches it took decades for our Nations
knowled that we had overreact acted and
mistreated in thousands of American
citizens I thought that perhaps we had
learned from our mistakes and would
never fall into the Trap of ostracizing
a whole segment of our society because
of the action of some
people now I see groups attempting to
demonize thousands of people because
they're
Islamic Islam is along with Judaism and
Christianity one of the three religions
that stem from a shared history thank
you I was a VA chap for 18 years I had
to learn about Islam so I could better
better Ministry to inur and heal
veterans that are American citizens and
are
Islamic following that I was working at
a cruss hospital managing chaplain I had
three Protestant
ministers a priest a nun a rabbi and an
Imam that way we could cover the people
there in that
hospital this is the way it seems to me
that we should all be working together
not only in chapy but in many areas of
our life as a volunteer firefighter for
44 years Bo finish
it I'll jump to the end I don't want my
grandchildren and my grandchildren's
grandchildren to look their history book
and find it in the second decade of the
21st century we made the same mistake
again demonizing a whole segment of our
society thank
you our next speaker is FY elmond and
the next five will be Carol Barker
Mohammad ID and I know I'm going to
start mispronouncing names and I
apologize Hamza elmund rahma elmund and
John
Mendez Mr thank you I would like to
start by thanking you all thanking you
for uh being there for our kids thanking
you for all the efforts that you do for
my for our kids I uh my name is f Elm I
am a father of four two of them
attending attending the hellborg County
Schools who are attending attending the
Islamic
schools um before I start I would like
to take your permission I would like for
all those who support the Muslim
Community in Tamba who are here in hbur
county and those to support care to
stand up and show us their
presence just to comment on what has
been already heard if those people don't
know what terrorism is and if those
people don't know what care is all about
they won't be here care is not a Tourist
Organization care is an organization
that's trying to bring both Christian
Muslims Jews to sit together in a table
and understand understand Islam
understand what Muslims and what Islam
is all
about my little one Hamza goes to Bonito
middle school he comes home during
Christmas he brings all that that's been
told all that been said about Christmas
and we sit down with him and we enjoy
learning more about Christmas he does
the same thing when Hanukah is there and
he does the same thing for whatever the
teacher asked him to say about Islam
this is the beauty of this country we
enjoy it we love it we are here citizen
we're going to stay here we're going to
live here you need to accept us and that
starts with our children thank
you Carol
Barker good afternoon my name is Carol
Barker I'm a Christian I live here in
Tampa I um am here because I believe in
Children Learning I believe in young
people learning about the world and the
people around us and the realities
around us and believe that we should not
be afraid of people who are different
than us we should be curious we should
be hungry for information I uh recommend
having experts come into the schools and
tell us about things um so that our
children might know more of the fact I
am a Christian but I do not force
Christianity on anyone else I share my
beliefs and other people may share
theirs but we don't have to protect
ourselves by putting so much distance
between ourselves and that which may be
different from ourselves I highly
recommend care coming to the school and
providing good information on a
religion that is practiced by so many
people in this world and in this country
thank you for hearing me and please
let's work against
xenophobia if you don't know what it is
find out
what they do in the Islam
countries please correct me when you get
to the
podium
name I would like to thank you all for
giving me the opportunity to talk here I
know the school board is not set up to
check packs but you can quote me on what
I'm saying and check whoever would like
to check of others especially the young
U gentleman who talked about his school
there are a lot of facts that need to be
checked there are a lot of stat
statements that need to be checked
they're not
facts uh I would like to give you a
little bit story about myself I came
from Syria in 1984 for college after
finishing higher school and finished
higher School finished College here and
then worked in this country for several
years and um as a professional
um for for big corporations and small
corporations and then I open my own
business during this time I get married
and have children my children are all in
um on our classes my son 19 the oldest
he is third year in college and he is 19
and he's in the honor um on the honor
rooll the same as the other children
that I had they attended um lisis
Elementary School in Temple Terrace
attended um Bonito Middle School in New
Tampa and uh worked in high school and
now the oldest is in college as I said
this is a typical story for people from
my generation who came to this country
and I came here to emphasize the point
that I don't like the fact that somebody
is painting me with the same picture as
every everybody else there are some
radical groups that are out there that
we all know that we uh do not agree with
we do not support but to paint me with
the same brush and put me in the same uh
frame I resist that and I came here to
defend my kids who go to public school
and to uh to clarify this when care goes
to or anybody goes to public schools to
uh clarify this this is this is um
something that's good for the community
to bring TI together thank you Hamza
El Hamza
El it's uh doesn't give me any pleasure
to to have to come down today I actually
have two daughters in Hillsboro County
school I'm a graduate of the hillsbor
County School System myself at
leato
um few words
transparency
Liberty
communication um the latest issue is
just the third actually issue I've heard
in Hillsboro County schools that has
raised my eyebrow as a father with with
children in in elementary
school I won't bring up the other two
issues at this time I don't want to
Cloud the the discussion but I will say
that uh you know having grown up in Tamp
I remember a time in eore City when
there were clubs down there and there
were I remember skin heads fighting and
uh you know basically uh it was a
problem and as much as I disliked that
word skin head and what they stood for
we do live in America and the justice
system care of the issues at that time
and so what I want to talk about during
this opportunity is as a father I'm
concerned about the process transparency
and
notification um I would just I would be
no happier if the Westborough Baptist
Church came to our school and spoke
about their issues I would not be happy
even as a gun owner if the NRA came and
spoke at the beest of a teacher um I
might agree with some of what they
discussed but I have friends who don't
own guns and they probably would be
offended by that our kids are there to
learn and they're there to learn under
the curriculum
so I can't understand why I hope there's
a process that will will be appropriate
so that as parents we know who's come to
speak to our kids because I'm not saying
that I would pull them out if it if this
happened again uh but I I do want to be
informed and please set up that process
thank you thank you Mr
good afternoon my name is z tah I would
like to thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak to you I would like
to thank all of you for serving our
students and serving the
community I have a daughter who in the
ninth grades who attends public school
it's very important for her to learn
about the cultures and religions from
the right sources ignorance is the enemy
of this country and every country amen
history is something already happened we
cannot change
it but we have to learn from it Islam
existed since the creation of Adam it is
submitting the will your will and
everybody's will to God we cannot ignore
it and it is positive contributions to
the civilization over the years we need
to teach our students about diversity
God created us in Nations and the tribes
so we may learn and know each other
if we teach our students about Hinduism
we bring a
Hindu what's wrong with bringing a
Muslim to teach about Islam what's wrong
with that they need to learn from the
right Source our society has Muslims
Christians Jews Hindus everybody even
atheists the students should learn the
truth about their neighbors from the
right Source Moses Prophet Moses peace
be upon him said in Exodus 2015 in the
10 commandments you shall not give a
false testimony against your neighbor
and I have seen people here earlier they
give false testimony about our neighbors
about care if care is a terorist
organization our government was shut it
down long time ago Jesus peace be him
said Jesus said the greatest command of
them own love your God and love your
neighbor Muhammad peace be upon him he
said you are not a believer if you go to
bed and sleep and your neighbor is
hungry and you know it that's what we
have to learn thank you very much I have
some more but thank you very
much
Tanner and Bob Dickerson will be next
thank you chairman and respect you
and get get the mic closer sir as close
as you can I know it's hard when you're
okay thank you thank you very much for
allowing me a moment or two here I would
like to just uh express myself with
regard to trying to understand as a
citizen as a leader in the
community as uh as a person who's worked
with children for a number of years
myself both in the educational system
and uh in the religious system
I'm trying to
understand
objectively uh as much as I can about
this situation and I appreciate very
much superintendent Al your efforts to
bring forth a workable solution here
it's not my desire to
be uh an
antagonist with regard to uh any other
religion I believe in respecting
everyone for their religion but I also
believe that other religions need to to
respect my
religion and uh I I think it's only fair
to expect that I have a
problem
uh I've done a little research
just moderate research and I have a
problem with some of the things I found
out about
care and it would seem to me that
if if the Muslims want to express
themselves in a way that is easily
respected by uh Christians Jews and
every other religious group that they
would not want a group that was in
question uh if I want if I were being
represented represented by uh uh thought
please sorry by uh if I wanted
representation for
Christianity the last group I'd want
would be the qlux clan members
representing
Christianity
[Applause]
jerson yes firstly I'd like to uh thank
everyone for giving me the opportunity
to speak and Madam superintendent I I
really appreciate the fact that you
brought this forward uh you're be uh to
be committed I'm sure the the board will
follow through
uh knowing what the communities uh
thoughts
on uh firstly I just uh I'd like to say
that uh this discussion that's taking
place
today will continue
to make sure that hillsb county has the
best educational system
possible and that educational system
would be
consistent with our American culture
thank
you in
hi Miss the bo thank you very much for
standing up for the right G my name is
gazi Ahmed I came from Yemen 1993 I
worked in Detroit for automotive company
for 13 years we built cars for this
country it's gotten tough in Detroit I
had to move to
Tamba and I dealt with care in Detroit
it's a well-known organization
not supporting anything they against the
religion or against them any
or against the
religion and um I have three kids
they're going to grow up
here and they're going to go to school
here and they're going to learn
everything here from other religions
from other
cultures and they're going to bring it
home to me and the mother and we'll have
to accept it we'll have to deal with it
we have to work together here not attack
each other thank
you thank you Mr go and while you are
coming up the next five will be Kimberly
Kelly Sean Kelly Linda skimas Joan Evans
and atio Coro and please correct my
pronunciation if I've V thank you
welcome okay thank you I'm Larry goom I
do the Radio Show in Clearwater called
the prescription addiction Radio Show
Breaking the silence as you all know we
have a serious drug epidemic in this
community that we live in I got to know
Hassan Sibly through the radio station
Hassan has appeared on the show called
Muslim Street that's the radio show
before mine on Sunday
nights Muslim Street's a great show for
community outreach and dialogue and I'm
assuming most of the people in this room
have never heard of Muslim Street
radio my point my point in this is
Hassan sibl and Malik aiz Malik does the
show Muslim
Street have reached out and they said
this area has a drug problem and we want
to do something about
it Hassan's sibling is reaching out to
the community to bring understanding and
dialogue this community needs Assan s
sibling has demonstrated to me only
positive comments and actions for this
community Hassan sibling has Illustrated
compassion and caring for our entire
Community I want to thank you board
members for standing strong against
negative comments and actions against
the minority religion in our area I'm
here to let you know that my positive
interactions with Hanan si in the Muslim
Community been
exemplary I think they warrant your
attention as for the speakers I'm
hearing some of the speakers it saddens
me that any attention is focused on
attempting to bring division within our
community please remain strong and
bringing awareness understanding and
education to our differences and common
goals I'm proud to stand here for Hassan
sibl and I hope he has the opportunity
opportunity to share his information
with more people in our community
thank you thank you
Mr Kimberly
Kelly welcome Miss
Kelly good to see you guys again how are
you I want to thank you guys for
bringing this agenda item it's much
appreciated and we look forward to
having this discussed and hearing your
views but as I'm listening to this I
asked you a question the very first
board meeting I was at why don't the
speakers have to go through
serve
why this is about protection to our
children I'm not talking about the Islam
faith I want someone in there to speak
to my child about that I don't want the
speaker that was there too he is not an
Imam he's not a cleric he didn't study
that in school that's not his
specialty that's where I'm coming from
we need to look at the credentials that
we're allowing to have
there I know the parents out here are
concerned both sides but my concern is
for the protection of our all our
children and I'm tired of hearing them
come up here and say thank you board for
taking my side thank you so much this
isn't about
sides this is about America Hillsboro
County our school system and if you
don't think that what car's pushing is G
dangerous let me tell you something I
received an email from someone else the
other day they're so worried about HB
1209 up in Tallahassee they sent an
email you know what hb29 protects our
constitution that's what this is about
this is about someone coming in teaching
what they're supposed to be teaching and
not expressing any other viewpoints or
teaching them what should be taught
thank you very much you
[Applause]
thank you thank you board uh this is the
third meeting that I've attended and I
can't be sing
anymore um I don't know if it's
ignorance or arrogance or a little of
both that I'm experiencing but let me
attempt to make clear what our our obje
Ive here is we're not looking to stifle
Educators or put them in a box we're
looking for Clear boundaries and we're
looking for a little bit of common
sense in a classroom Mr shiy asked the
question don't you want to know about
Terror don't you want your children to
know about terrorism the answer is
yes I just don't want it taught by care
I want to taught Nazism but I don't want
it taught by the Aran
Brotherhood in the last board
meeting board member edgeone expressed
concerns that the NAACP would be
targeted next unless they're funding
rockets and bombs somewhere that's a
ludicrous
argument uh and it's designed to inflame
and
divide this is not about race and it's
not about religion it's about prot in
our children from a group that Advocates
hate and violence to settle their
differences care is known for this we
didn't put them on a terrorist watch
list the government did amen that's
right it's hard to believe that we
cannot find any better representation
for Islam than
this look around at the people here in
the faces CU you're going to see them
again in election time
[Applause]
their will thank
you you don't need to wait to be called
Linda skus is next then Joan Evans then
atio
corbo just you know the next person is
welcome just come right up hello here
used to work with the FBI until it was
discredited by the FBI the issue is care
not Islam don't confuse one with the
other that's right care is an
organization that protects terrorism and
is against any free speech against them
and the terrorist they protest right the
FBI does not trust care they want to
speak at high schools they like to
intimidate you on the board are being
intimidated by
care why you
allow shle to speak for Islam why not a
local Imam political correctness has
taken the front seat to everything these
days that's right everyone is afraid to
offend care is a front for Hamas
according to the FBI care speaks for
Hamas the five people on the board are
allowing this out of fear of political
correctness or they might have received
a phone call who knows the care people
know Allah the way My Cat Knows a mouse
care apologizes for terrorism shame on
you the five who came to political
correctness all they wanted at the last
meeting was to have a workshop with
parents and Mr Shi I believe in free
speech too bad Hamas I mean care doesn't
right also back in 2007 there was a tel
evangelist who spoke on W TV live prayer
with Bill Kelly
it was cancelled the station and its
parent company CBS received a letter
earlier this month K asked CBS executive
to remove Keller's nightly talk show
from channel 44 the CBS own station that
well anyway the group was upset about a
recent Spate of broadcast by Keller that
despar Islam and the Mohamad the prophet
Muhammad thank you ma'am
[Applause]
Evans good
afternoon prior to President Obama
speaking at the first day of school to
students parents and teachers had
concerns as to the content of the speech
and lessons plans he was to give
them at uh at that time the president of
the United States published his speech
prior to his telecast to the
children some parents kept their
children home parents requested children
not be present during this
telecast now the board has to answer to
how they can approve of any organization
to speak without the approval of parents
or with full knowledge that care is not
is is most conver uh
controversial um as it has been
associated with terrorist
organizations and money laundering thank
you thank
you the next five speakers are Mustafa
dle Genevie La Cavalier Bale Dr chandr
Saria Michael Weston and Reverend
Bernice Howell Jackson Mr car good
afternoon
thank ha was founded in June 1994 under
the tentacles of the Muslim
Brotherhood and then I got this from the
website Council on American Islamic
relations the Muslim Brotherhood is not
an organization that is a proven friend
of the United States of America or the
non-muslim world so how can we allow our
school system to allow care to come into
our schools and talk to our students to
tell them or teach them about care Islam
or the Muslim
countries presently the Hillsboro School
District has 91% of its schools leveled
at an A or B and under the new state
ruling that was being worked on today it
may be down to
47 uh% of the people students will be in
A or B level
and you want to waste our children's
time having them instructed on a subject
that should not be allowed until
Christianity can be
discussed once once people of the
Islamic faith learn to live with others
of different faiths in their own Muslim
countries with respect and religious
tolerance then I can change my beliefs
and feel for them and for them coming
into our schools
if our government will not let any
Christian discussion emblems or prayers
in the classrooms then why must we allow
Islam
right government and the school system
is responsible to its people so please
be responsible to us and respect our
wanting that care not be allowed to come
in and be instructors in our schools
thank you
mus dandley Genevie Bale Dr
chandr good afternoon my name is j I'm
Sorry Miss Musta nley not
here I'm sorry well you can go ahead and
then we'll have him I just I'm trying to
keep trag go ahead that's fine no
problem my name is jevie Bale and I have
three children at ten Hammond Elementary
School in Odessa I am here today to
discuss um my oldest Madison who's in
fifth grade I'm sorry ma'am we we are
only talking about care and guest
speakers right now you're T and I they
told me at the entrance I'm just here to
question your magnet program at Walker
Middle School Mustafa
dley my name is uh musty um like unlike
a lot of these people here I actually
don't have any students at Hillsboro
County um one of the reasons I came to
Hillsboro County is uh I understand
they're very accepting they're very open
and uh at the root of this issue is uh
is education now one day if I decide to
settle down here maybe have kids um I'd
really like my kids to be in an open and
accepting atmosphere um and like I said
uh at the root of this is the issue of
Education now nobody's uh advocating
prayer in schools Etc all of this uh
although we're asking is uh for free and
open education now Christianity is
taught in the in the schools just as
just as please be respectful of all the
speakers
Li um so like I said I just want uh I
just want there to be free and open
education now I don't believe there's a
problem with care care is a very uh
they're nonprofit organizations they're
very open they fight for civil rights
something that we seem to be liking a
lot in today's society um again I don't
want to take a lot of your time but I
just wanted to uh point out that um
again education is uh is key here and
it's not the heart of this debate and uh
there really should not be a problem
with care coming in and and merely
offering information they're not
offering hate they're not offering
they're not trying to convert anybody
they're just offering information and if
people can't accept that information
then uh perhaps public school isn't for
them thank you thank you Mr D Dr Sia
Dr sah not
here um Reverend Bernice Powell Jackson
and I'm going to call the next five
Larry goldbam Mel
undery Bishop Chuck Lee Joyce Hamilton
Henry and Reverend Russell
Meyer welcome thank you thank you for
the opportunity to be here today I am
Reverend ber Powell Jackson I serve as a
local church pastor here in Hillsboro
County but I also serve as the president
of the World Council of churches for
North America in both capacities I've
had many occasions to work across Faith
lives including with many members from
the Muslim Community here in Tampa our
church has worked with care for many
years both preceding Mr shi's time as
executive director and including the
time that he's been here both Mr Shi and
K have worked hard to open lines of
communication with the m musl community
and to educate non-muslims about a faith
that too many of us are ignorant about
that ignorance has led to stereotyping
and misunderstanding across our nation
and across our world in my role as
president of the World Council of
churches I have had the opportunity to
co-moderate a planning committee for an
International Christian Muslim
consultation which was held in
2010 one of the many things that came
out of that meeting of Christian and
Muslim Muslim leaders from around the
world with a commitment to expanding
educational opportunities about each
other's
Faith thus care is a perfect
organization to help do this work and we
are blessed to have them as a part of
our community the fact is that there are
more than a billion Muslims in our world
and perhaps two billion Christians and
we must learn how to get along or our
world will not survive to use Dr King's
word words men often hate each other
because they fear each other they fear
each other because they don't know each
other they don't know each other because
they cannot communicate they cannot
communicate because they are separated
if Tampa wants to be a world class City
then it must encourage education about
different
religions and to have students graduate
from our school system without such
education means our students will not be
equipped for 21st century leadership
thank you thank
you Larry
go Larry
goom M underbake or under
bakey okay Bishop Chuck Lee
com okay are you n
undery good afternoon and thank you for
allowing me to speak and as said I'm Mel
undery and I'm the director of friends
of Human Rights
and we've worked with care for many
years now both locally and nationally
and it's a really a wonderful
organization it's very moderate
definitely does not support terrorism
they support civil liberties and they
support uh understanding between
cultures and I've worked with Hassan
shley for also and he's also wonderful
to work with and he's very knowledgeable
he's um very well spoken and I'm just
happy to have him my
community and I'm also a former
educational researchers and so I've
known Dr Milano for a lot of years and
she's I'm sure you know she's a
wonderful teacher one of the better or
Innovative teachers I've ever known and
she's very dedicated to teaching her
students and so because of knowing them
I was very surprised really and then
much say shocked of the attack against
these people and I uh I think the the
reaction of misinformed group shows the
need for them to continue what they're
doing the need for diversity education
and I wanted to come here today to thank
you all for supporting you know standing
up against bigotry and hatred and uh
ignorance so again thank you very much
and please
continue if by some chance anyone is
here who signed up online and has not
checked in please do that Bishop welcome
I'm Bishop Chuck
Lee president of the part of Council of
churches and I'm a board member of the
National Council of churches but more
importantly um I've lived a Tamp all my
life and both my father and grandfather
were came up through the Hillsboro
County school system and it served them
well and it's a system that despite all
all kinds of roadblocks has educated
children and and done it well and I
think in these difficult Economic Times
you have all kinds of budget restraints
I'm really grateful that you take every
opportunity to use all the resources you
can to educate our children for the
future for a very difficult time that's
coming ahead they need to know all they
can about all the different cultures
that are in America so that they can
bring about a
society where we respect and care for
one
another using the opportunity you have
to bring Islamic speakers into the
school it's really something wonderful
and I I'm very
grateful you know I know times are hard
and it's hard to get get the kind of
education for our children that you
would
like using these resources that in this
case were
free and I don't think he's a
terrorist and I do know them I'm a vetan
thank you thank
you Hamilton
Henry welcome thank you good
afternoon my name is Joyce Henry and I'm
the director of fla regional office of
the ACLU based in Tampa I applaud you
for allowing this open discourse of this
very important
issue we at ACLU um believe that people
should not be afraid of learning about
other view points in the classroom if
the classroom isn't a safe place to
exchange ideas without interference what
is where is we are in support of open
dialogue free from stereotype and
Prejudice Embrace an open that debate
not any specific group or
Viewpoint no one ever benefited from
limiting
discussion and limiting a debate if
people don't like what care is saying
they should be invited to present too
they too should be invited to present
and present an other Viewpoint as well
we feel that it's very important to
allow for once again a open discourse on
all issues thank
you Reverend Meyer and the next five
will be Naina parar T mmed Lea
abdulaziz
imia and Eva Lewis welcome Reverend M
thank you um I want to thank the board
for engaging in civil discourse like
this it's extremely important and I
would wish that all of the students of
hillbro County could actually watch and
listen to this kind of uh Civic
conversation it's essential for learning
the skills of how to cooperate and
belong in our world today my name is
Russell Meer I live in Tampa Palms my
oldest son graduated from the IB program
at King High School I've been a Lutheran
Pastor for 28 years in the Evangelical
Lutheran Church in America I'm the
executive director of the Florida
Council of churches and I work across
North America and various epical and
Interfaith uh
relations I speak with experience and
expertise in how to work with all
religions and we're currently trying to
build an innerfaith uh organization in
Tampa Bay I speak in favor of care and
other competent religiously aligned
groups they should be able to present
their perspectives in our public schools
in an informative nonpr prosing manner
as the Supreme Court said we should
teach about religions rather than
practice religions in public schools the
Treaty of triple signed in
1797 says this government is not in any
sense founded on the Christian religion
it has no character of enmity against
the laws religion or
transil of Muslims our actual history is
one of turning against newcomers out of
fear of the unknown Germans Italians
Irish Jews Catholics Eastern Europeans
Chinese Japanese Hispanics Pentecostals
have all been targets at some time in
our past these people their cultures and
their religions have proven to be
American America's strength the same can
be said of care and of other Muslim
organizations they deserve to
be before I before I call the next
person Scott beish if you're still here
because you didn't use all your time and
I wasn't clear that everybody gets one
chance um you can speak now or why don't
we give you one minute
now and then we'll hear the next five
thank you sorry this is we don't usually
have quite this much excitement thank
you madam chair I want to quickly point
out that this is not a debate about
Islam or any other um organizations U
cultures in the school system it is
about screening who comes in to speak
about those
cultures when it to
in the Holy Land Foundation case k was
named an unindicted co-conspirator in
the US District Court where they were
unsuccessfully tried to get their name
taken off that list K was born out of
the
IAP another terrorist
organization I sent each and every one
of you a
packet with the supporting
documentation evidence that was entered
into a court of
law not made of statements but evidence
in the court of law thank you thank you
Mr before I call if you have a celf
phone beeper pager or other noise maker
that you haven't yes turned off please
do so
nvar and if I've murdered your name
please correct
me okay hello my name is NE student at
the University of South Florida and a
product of the Hood County School System
I seated the Schoolboard meetings about
a speaker that came into the APR world
history class A few years ago I was
sitting in AP World History Class what I
learned in that class has been
invaluable to me learned about how the
world was shaped and what it is today
and I learned about so many different
cultures and religions my world viie was
truly enriched if I thought I didn't
agree with something or thought
something was a little bit shady I would
have asked questions that my own
research talk to my parents and friends
I would have loved to have had more
speakers come and explain history of
their religion in detail
my intelligence would have been insulted
if had anyone's say I was being
brainwashed in that class watching the
Hillsboro school board meeting meetings
I felt I was catapult to back into the
past I knew that there was still vast
amounts of discrimination out there in
the world and I no ignorant people exist
yet the biger Tre I witnessed at these
school board meetings left me
flabbergasted it's not only that these
people are making comments that show
their lack of knowledge about the cause
they're so adamantly supporting but
their comments are hateful and so
insanely ignorant it all goes back to
Identity everyone does it categorizing a
group of people and assuming they share
all the same characteristics nuances
beliefs that they all act identically
the missing key here is that we're all
individual human beings you cannot
stereotype and can't categorize in
history especially history of America
there's been so much discrimination
which we all have learned by now that
how important it is to get to know the
group of people we're so adamantly
against your feelings about them might
change during the Civil Rights Movement
there was an incredible amount of
discrimination but there were many
non-african-americans that started to
realize that freedom was for everyone
Martin Luther King put it in this way in
his I Have a Dream speech The Marvelous
new militancy which is a Gul the Negro
Community must not lead us to dist of
all white people for many of our White
Brothers as evidence by the presence
here today have come to realize that
their Destiny side up with our destiny
they' have come to realize that their
freedom is inextricably bound to our
freedom I realized that my freedom is
bound to the freedom of all Americans no
matter their religious affiliation the
biggly and misinformation that has been
on display already twice at the school
board meetings is really stening we
cannot let our education be guided by
those that do not respect diversity
[Applause]
hi my name is and I went to the
Hillsboro uh County Public Schools and
it's difficult growing up in a community
where so many people misunderstand you
misunderstand your faith and just make
fun of you or call you a terrorist and
all this other nonsense all streaming
from ignorance it was to the extent that
when I was profiled by teachers quote
unquote jokingly some people who came to
me and asked me about what Islam is and
why people are making fun of you it is
all due to ignorance and getting to know
each other is key to stop this ignorance
the protest against one of the prominent
Muslim Community leaders and Imam of the
local Mosk only show the importance of
raising our children with proper
understanding of diverse faiths that
make up our community I would I would I
would had a much easier time growing up
in hillsbor County public schools had my
classmates knew the truth about my faith
it did not judge or stereotype me
programs like the one Mr shibly gave go
a long way to Foster healthy
communication environments especially
for the Muslim Students who every day
face mistreatment discrimination and get
attacked because of their faith it is
not ever about which religion is
prominent in our Public Schools it is
about the love we had as friends we
Muslims were a minority in our school
but through friendship and bonds we
understood one another to the extent
that even our teachers accepted our
differences because of the influences
Christian and Muslims alike had we as
American Muslims realize we are a
minority in our great nation and have
accepted there are people who are
different around us we implore the
people around us to do the same I want
to end with what one student who
attended Hassan shi's lecture at the
public high school had to say I attended
Hassan shi's presentation on Islam and
found it perfectly appropriate and it
tied into our study in the postclassical
era I don't feel like I was being
converted and certainly I don't feel
like I was being brainwashed David kton
founder of the president of the FFA goes
as far to say folks we are watching
islamization of America in action here's
the problem Kon can't get it out out of
his thick skull that shibly doesn't have
the intention of converting or
brainwashing us now apparently
ridiculous there's a fine line between
preaching and teaching if ignorance is
bliss then Kon must be the happiest man
in the
[Applause]
world and um I'm very honored to be
speaking today at the school board
meeting today I want to share with you
guys a unity prayer that I worked when I
worked for my senator in Washington DC
Senator Bill Nelson I was part of the
Muslim Congressional musl
Association and I was asked to read this
prayer after representative gords was
shot and there was a lot of
misunderstanding going on in Congress
and I was very happy to have the
opportunity to be a part of the
Congressional Muslim staffers
Association and share this prayer no the
founding fathers crafted a constitution
and founding principles that make our
United States a unit a unque place in
the world that we live in a place where
people of all ethnicities and faiths not
only share the ability to truly belong
to this nation but also have the ability
to share the same vision a vision of a
nation that upholds and Embraces
religious rights and personal freedoms a
nation that allows us to reach our
common Dream by granting us the right to
engage in public discourse through a
common understanding of our equal
constitutional rights rights that must
not be taken for granted but instead
constantly utilized because they impose
upon us the responsibility of political
engagement we must always remember that
a democracy is only as effective as the
amount of political participation of its
people now with that being said I'd like
to briefly speak about the Muslim
chapter of the American story Islam in
America has Deep Roots one-third of the
slaves that arrived on ships hundreds of
years ago were Muslim Thomas Jefferson
one of the founding fathers of this
country owned the Quran and wrote about
the many contributions of Islam to
civilization including the creation of
our great nation the freeze at top the
Supreme Court of the United States
United States shows the Quran being held
as a source of law in the House of
Representatives appear the faces of
Islamic lawmakers which every member of
Congress can see as he or she votes the
history of Islam in America may be
little known but cannot be denied the
ideal set out in the Constitution such
as equality freedom and democracy have
been I almost done sorry have been laid
in the Quran making American Muslims
responsible oh
[Applause]
sorry God's peace and blessings
be God's peace and blessings be upon all
of you those of you who are officials
charged with the weighty responsibility
that you have but I also pray that God's
peace and blessings will be upon
everyone who's in this audience and who
has Found the courage and the time to
come out and take a stand on this issue
I think it's important and healthy for
our democracy that this debate is and
this discourse is taking place I
remember back uh in the late 60s and
early 70s when I was a resident here I
knew Dr Shelton personally I knew uh
Reverend Dr Alon Lowry personally I knew
Cecil estri personally and new Sam
grandell personally and at at one time I
was one of those who was in fact leading
and arousing angry voices to come down
and assail the I see you're not in your
head you remember me and they come down
and assil the board because of the
tension that existed at the time and the
difficult
difficult and challenging issues that
the board was facing uh but some U wise
person elevated your position in this
room so that you could see beyond
emotionalism and Beyond the immediacy of
the situation and look and think and act
and decide long term I'd like to just
make two points very quickly first of
all I have grandchildren in the hillsbor
County School System one who will
graduate this year with a 4.8 average
from Tampa Bay Tech she's already been
in the school her mother my oldest
daughter is a devout Christian my mother
has been a member of the same church the
church in which I was raised for 65
years my sister is a trustee in that
church and has been a trustee and a me a
member of that church for 63 years I
have been a Muslim for 40 years and an
IM man for 35 years one final comment in
America The Fountain the one of the key
principles is that you're innocent until
proven guilty an indictment or
insinuation or act or accusation is not
an indictment therefore thank you so
much I seea
Lewis so the next
five are Tom Earl Rana Bernie waren
Clark I'm sorry Warren Clark I even know
I can read Clark joris lito and Malik
aiz Tom Earl
hello my name is Tom Earl I want to
thank you for your time education is
essential to the formation of a
successful Society diversity is
something I value dearly and I believe
diversity is an essential element to
education I am here to thank the board
for working to create an our schools a
healthy knowledge of world cultures and
religions and for including Islam in
these efforts
I appreciate your integrity especially
in a time where misunderstandings and
misconceptions surround Islam
crosscultural interactions are Paramount
and our United goal of ending all forms
of
discrimination therefore I sincerely
appreciate you supporting our teachers
inviting diverse and educated educated
speakers like Mr Hassan shii from care
to speak at our schools and for the
record Hanan shii is an educator he is
an Imam a father an Interfaith Advocate
and a US citizen but he is not a
terrorist recently a terrorist an
alleged terrorist was found in Tampa and
the FBI publicly thanked the Muslim
Community and care for this effort I
hear people Express their objections are
not with Islam but are with care but to
me what I hear is the reiteration of The
Stereotype that Muslims are terrorists
Islam and other world cultures and
religions are not only cultures and
religions of the world but are also
cultures and religions of proud US
citizens in conclusion I applaud the
school board for doing their part to
knowledge and place of ignorance and
understanding and place of fear and
misunderstanding Thank
youa Bernie or Raina Bernie fortunately
you recognize my mispronunciations of
your
name good afternoon
um I I wear a couple of hats and I want
to talk to this I wear a couple of hats
and I want to uh talk to the school
board wearing both of them first of all
um I'm a mother I have three children
who have gone through the Hillsboro
County School District and I just want
to thank the board for giving them an
excellent education that is second to
none um now our children are a future I
look at them as our future Business
Leaders our future political leaders
future humanitarians and now when they
go out into the world they're going to
be dealing with people from all cultures
all Races all nationalities we want them
to rise to the top we don't want to
handicap them by going out into a world
where they don't have knowledge of the
people that they're dealing with as part
of the educational system isn't it our
duty to give them the tools with which
they can they have the competitive
Advantage not to hinder
them um we need to show them that the
actions of a few misguided people don't
necessarily have to taint an entire
religious group we need to show them we
need to teach them that they need to
look beyond the typical stereotypes and
get to evaluate a person the people that
they are going to be dealing with
working with and making business deals
and political decisions upon so if we
don't equip them with that knowledge and
we don't expose them to everything
that's out there we're doing them a
great disservice
secondly as a law student I have full
faith in our legal system and if and
when the government of the United States
decides that care is indeed a terrorist
organization which it has not then of
course it should not be allowed into our
schools but that decision has not been
made and I think that we should have
trust in the government of the United
States in the FBI and in the justice
system that we can trust them to talk
about students thank you thank
[Applause]
you sorry I couldn't pronounce your name
thank you glad to be with you all today
um I want to tell you just a story that
I think dramatizes or and focuses the
way in which we learn from each other
when we have the chance to see one
another as human beings about two years
ago I got a call from the coalition of
amle Farm Workers and they were going to
have several rallies in Tampa and they
were going to bring up 250 Farm Workers
to Tampa to be in those rallies with
other supporters and the reason why was
to ask for a raise in the pinking rate
for tomatoes it had not been risen since
1979 uh and then they were going to
March over to Lakeland to do the same
problem was that the group that was
going to host them and provide them
housing that night or let sleep in their
fellowship hall floor had packed out 3
days before Warren can you find some
place uh for these people to stay and I
called up a lot of the churches and also
an Islamic organization that I had
worked with and asked and one after
another after another said sorry we
can't do it liability you name it lots
of lots and lots of reasons and then I
got a call from n Salam who is with the
Tampa Bay um is is the Islamic community
of Tampa Bay and he said we talked about
it as leaders in our community and
Reverend Clark we will host them I was
so taken aback that I said are you sure
and he said yes when they came it was an
opportunity for Muslims that were
worshiping that night and for Farm
Workers who were there about to sleep
that night to bump into each other and
to see oh these are Farm Workers and so
this this is what they're like they're
just they're human beings and oh these
are Muslims never seen a Muslim before
and they're human beings that's what you
all are supporting in this kind of
education is the opportunity for us to
see one another as human beings and that
is so important even a value of us doing
this here tonight thank you there are
humans here and there are humans here we
are all human beings thank you
[Applause]
well thank you for letting me come I
don't have any notes there are a few
things that I want to say I'm an
independent journalist I've recently
returned from Bethlehem where I live
this is my fourth time coming from
Bethlehem I want to say I live in a
community which is is now about 95%
Muslim and 5% Christian as you know
Bethlehem is believed to be the place
where Jesus was born at one time it was
mainly Christian most of the Christians
have moved out Muslims have moved in
it's Community there Muslims and
Christians get along I can walk the
streets in Bethlehem day and night and
be assured that I won't be accosted that
I won't be
bothered 5 miles away is Jerusalem
Israeli Jews are not permitted to go
into Bethlehem there's a 30 foot wall
between Bethlehem and Jerusalem two holy
cities Jews do come in and they unite
when they can with Christians and
Muslims and they are all working at a
grass
Grassroots Organization for peace you
don't hear about it in our uh media here
however there are many many
organizations both Jews Jewish
organization Christian organization and
international organizations working on
getting to know one another on
nonviolent uh ways of getting together
thank you thank you
and before you speak I will call the
last group of speakers um and I think a
few may not be here but I'll call all
the names and whoever's here can line up
Lois price Amed
ID Kelly Clen ricken Terry kle Hassan
chii and Nan
Desai welcome Mr AAS thank you very much
to thank the Hillsboro County schools
for listening to me Susan Valdez uh help
represents my district very
West Chase I do not have any uh children
in Hillsboro County school though I live
in Hill Hillsboro County for an excess
of 12 years and paid nearly $50,000 in
property taxes having said that uh hate
has entered the Public Square uh
Hillsboro County Schools uh has to uh
defend against hate and hate will have
you think uh in his deceptive form that
this is not about Islam this is not
about uh you know the Quran it's not
about anything yes it is absolutely is
and I think that if we look back in
history uh come from a people who were
brought to the shores against their will
in shackles hate greeted them at the
shores over 400 years ago they hung us
from trees and they tightened their
ropes they oil the
chains and they
loosen uh nothing for over 31 years and
we work from sun up to sun down and I
recognize hate when I feel it I
recognize hate when I see it hate
changes his stripes from white shirts
and white hoods to brown shirts that
Hitler put on his his people and to red
shirts that I've sit in the back of this
room and I felt the hate that hate
produces and I'm going to tell you
something about hate and it's deceptive
form that is an illusion hate will have
you think uh that they are not here to
darken the uh Public Square but as feder
uh nii said that God is dead why because
hate has entered the public square and a
cloud has come over Hillsboro County and
I'm counting on you guys to defend
against hate and I'll stand with you
thank
you before I call the next speaker I'm
going to ask my friends in communication
do we have someone else Mr hegerty do we
have someone else that we need to add to
the
list all right let's from Miss
price were you here before no okay no
I'm sorry I'm just I'm trying
to welcome I'm sorry thank you I am Lois
pra and I thank you for the opportunity
to talk I am the mother of two Hillsboro
County School teachers but I come to you
more importantly as the grandmother of
two little ones to whom I entrust their
care uh to all of you and the people you
represent day in and day out
out as a member of friends of Human
Rights Women of Faith and other Civic
and religious groups I have worked with
care best in the whole County and um I'm
here today because um I'd like first off
I do want to thank each of you for your
service I know that your first order of
uh concern is for our students and I
appreciate that I am a geography teacher
and I feel it's important that we teach
our children to respect all religions we
have the opportunity to celebrate
cultures religions Customs throughout
the world and like each of you on this
board I am against any discrimination
based on religion I was raised as a
Mormon my son is serving a mission in
Slovakia I know a thing too about
persecution I speak to you today not
only as a teacher but as a mother based
on religious beliefs um I think that we
should be open to invite all religions
to come to speak in our
classrooms but I would ask you to please
put a policy in place that would not
support the speakers from care to come
into our classrooms and the reason I ask
for that is because there's clearly ties
by the federal government that shows
that they are connected to
terrorism I would also ask you to
promote patriotism and to promote the
you United States Constitution Sharia
law would subvert the Constitution of
the United States of
America like to close by saying in in
behalf of women's rights behalf of my
daughters behalf of fighting against
Sharia law and standing for the
Constitution I ask you to please not
allow care to speak into our Public
Schools I would invite any Muslim to
come to speak to my classroom and talk
about the five pillars of Islam it's a
beautiful thing but I would not want
[Applause]
care if you're here because you don't
think like ter an organism organization
that has been linked to terrorism should
be in CL please stand up thank you very
much Mia first I want to thank you for
recognizing that there's a problem that
needs a solution and for putting 901a on
the agenda we've looked at it I think
it's a step in the right direction would
like to have an opportunity to speak
with you more about it we will continue
to come back to these meetings until
this issue is
resolved I've heard a lot of speakers
from care basically proponents of care
or uh speakers on behalf of care and
they've done the same thing that a
number of you board members have done
and that is you've Anno You' avoided
they've avoided the heart of the issue
that is our concern Our concern is not
about Islam we recommended an
organization that has no link to
terrorism to come into the classroom
it's a Muslim organization the uh
Islamic Association for democracy and
missil and I spoke about that you may
have missed it in the emails that you've
received but go check your emails it's
public record um we
aren't here to bash the teachers so I'm
going to ask you please if you discuss
this after we all
speak address the issue that we're here
about that we're concerned about care
has been directly linked to terrorism in
the Holy Land Foundation trial they
tried three times to have their names
expunged and the judge said there was
ample evidence the only reason they're
unindicted co-conspirators is because
after the first group of conspirators
was convicted on 100 counts of the 108
counts that were
brought the Obama justice department
quashed any further prosecutions Mr Shi
will follow me I'm sure that's not by
accident he will try and apologize about
that and offer you some other
alternative all I can ask you to do is
address Our concern and look at the
facts
final our final group of speakers final
final Mr shibl n and Desai Christina
latchford Amber Kelly and
viol
cabara Mr shiing with everything that's
been said I'm just waiting for the
marshals to jump out and arrest me at
any moment uh that's a joke guys uh
before I begin I would request an
extension of my time humbly there's been
three meetings against me and I would
request that I do have a few additional
moments maybe five minutes six minutes
sorry
no take your three your two minutes
please that's fine I I would request my
minutes just restart my name is uh
respective board members and Community
leaders I would like to begin by
thanking you for this opportunity to
come and share our thoughts as people of
diverse faiths and beliefs standing
United for a diverse tolerant and
welcome Community my name is Imam Hassan
chii that's right Imam Hassan shii uh
you've heard from those that know me
those that know care those that have
known us all our lives have nothing but
good things to say about us and those
that are promoting this hatred and false
allegations never even came to our
office or or came to know us don't know
anything about us unfortunately uh the
reality is there's been so many lies
that have been said today uh I feel like
I have to come out here and prove that
the world isn't flat again you know
that's how outrageous these false
statements have been said um over the
course of the past few weeks our local
community has been visited by a small
but vocal minority that has insisted on
spreading untruths and misinformation
about Islam and Muslims living here in
Hillsboro I've been reluctant to come
and say anything so as not to set a bad
for other minorities should every leader
of every minority be forced to stand
here and defend against the common
misconceptions against themselves do we
expect African-Americans Japanese Jews
Catholics and minorities to defend
against xenop xenophobic conspiracy
theories leveled against them
nonetheless we have come today to show
you that those who promote fear and
hatred of what they consider the other
do not speak uh on behalf of the
majority of your constituents tonight
you heard from a number of commentators
who have shared with you their thoughts
and Views about the inv vent of Muslims
in our community their commitment that
we all share to upholding the law the
commitment to defending Liberties
established in our Constitution and
condemning the unfortunate stereotyping
and hurtful accusations hurled at
Muslims like me living peacely and
proudly as practitioners of Islam but
also as proud Americans with the Pledge
of Allegiance in our hearts to our
nation under God with a sworn commitment
to liberty and justice for all citizens
and residents you have heard demography
today and hateful comments and these
comments are coming at me why because in
my eyes and in the eyes of the vast
majority of Muslims across our great
nation and land to practice Islam to be
a Muslim means to be a proud American we
see no difference because by definition
our religious values are the same as
American values my opponents disagree
with me about these things and thus they
have targeted me and falsely slandered
me a Muslim extremist have called me an
Infidel and guys have called me a
terrorist I'm running this meeting and I
said I would give him 30 seconds more we
have sat and listened respectfully I
would ask you to cons continue to sit
and listen listen respectfully you have
30 seconds I just want to say that that
Muslim extremists like osak have called
me an Infidel these guys are calling me
a terrorist if anything of these things
were true come on really I wouldn't be
standing here I wouldn't be a proud
member of the bar for the past 10 years
Muslims have had to deal with these
kinds of false accusations for a decade
since 911 we have stood tall silently
and held in the tears in our eyes out of
love for our countrymen by which I mean
our fellow Americans and that is because
of Islam's teaching of compassion I'm
here today to bridge the gap forming in
our society and help bring about
understanding we cannot let those are
promoting hatred and bigotry raise a
flag of victory over our schools thank
you and God bless you God Bless
America
the ladies and gentlemen of the school
board thank you for the opportunity I'm
n in the side and I'm a Hindu the third
major religion of the world and I'm also
the president of the Hindu temple of
Florida uh in
Tampa I would like to bring out here
that diversity is extremely important in
our
education although I come from a country
and of Hindus with probably the world's
highest persecution ever took place uh
for the Hindus we have always espoused
diversity and equality we strongly
recommend that all the Rel legence be
afforded as a matter of fact encourage
the school system be encouraged to
require that speakers from different
religions come and speak to their class
because what we have found is that our
textbooks continue with the
misconceptions that have been ingrained
over the years and it's not the fault of
the students it's not the fault of the
parents in our F thee it's been going on
for several years and it's what we are
finding out is that that's quite
shocking and allowing different
religious groups to come and present and
explain it gives a great opportunity to
the people who are practicing the
religion to explain what the truth is I
once
again I represent here Hindus and there
are several other religions that are
from India there are jism there is
Sikhism there's Buddhism and I recommend
that all the religions be afforded
opportunity to come and present their uh
explain to the youth explain to our
students as many speakers have say that
our our students are going to go out and
be the leaders of the world and the only
way they can be is they understand all
the cultures and all the religions thank
you thank
you Chris
thank you very much for taking the time
to listen to everybody I do appreciate
it my name is Christina lford um I am
the mother and the spouse of a 27 year
veteran in the military just recently
returned home here after his retirement
within the year my husband has deployed
twice in warrant care so I have stayed
home and taken care of children one who
has Sor disabilities
I think it's
important just as you would uh I saw
your diligence in looking over your
contracts and if the tees are crossed
and the eyes are dotted and who's going
to sign first and all these things and
anytime you want to hire somebody to do
something like work on your house you
vent them and you try to find out really
what they're about and what is their
record and can I count on them and I
stand here to say and to know that care
does have ties
to care is merely an instrument for the
camel's NOS getting Under the
Tent I do not have hate in my heart but
I do recognize an
ideology that is damaging and I would
not subject my children to it and if you
insist on allowing them to come in do
your due diligence and I would say to
every one of you who are members of care
will you sign a
statement in front of these people and
this whole community that says you
renounce Hamas and Hezbollah as
terrorist organizations prior to
entering
[Applause]
our and Mr shley your influence is duly
noted if you can do that because I have
dined with Muslims I have traveled and I
have met them and I understand them but
that ideology there is no change in it
and once you get the no under the
camel's NOS of the 10th there is no
turning back so do your due diligence
thank you Amber
Kelly I want to thank you for having the
opportunity to speak first of all I want
to say I'm a graduate of the Florida
Public Schools I attended USF for my
undergraduate degree and I do understand
the sunsh Sunshine State requirement
I just want to address first of all for
anybody that says this is a hate message
I have friends that are Muslim I've had
friends that are Muslim for more than 10
years I have lived in Muslim countries I
have studied Muslim countries I have
worked on Fally funded programs in
Muslim countries this is not about
hate I I understand this is not an
attack on Muslim this is a concern with
the organization that was invited into
the school somebody before me said that
we need the right people teaching Islam
and I would agree I understand this is a
sunshine state requirement we need to
address we need tolerance we should you
know if you're a Christian Jesus taught
you should love your neighbor we need to
do that we need to practice that we need
to understand that on the other hand
we're talking about an organization you
know that doesn't necessarily have that
same goal one of the other speakers
mentioned non prosing nature that it's
okay to teach as long as we're not
prizing but one of the found joint
founders of care said muslim Americans
have a duty to deliver the message of
Islam and Islam isn't in America to be
equal to any other Faith but to become
dominant that's
prizing I'm willing to admit that some
of these members of care over here
they're not terrorists they do good
works they're good members of the
community but we're talking about what
the organization itself was founded for
what are its principles what does it
want lastly
like I said care doesn't have to be all
bad if they are indeed the pr branch of
Hamas or the Muslim Brotherhood they are
going to do good things in the community
that would further their goal lastly I
just want to say that care is not the
only Muslim organization that could come
in and speak why does it have to be this
specific
organization thank
[Applause]
you
Kari our last speaker is vul Kari
welcome
Mr honorable school board
members and respected audience
members I'm vul Kara I'm a physician who
practices pain management as a
speciality of anesthesiology in
Hillsboro
County when I've listen to all the
comments I hear a lot of subjectivity so
I wanted to bring
some fresh Viewpoint being a physician I
look for objective Solutions and when I
looked at this subject I came across a
teacher's guide to religion in the
public school that has been published by
First Amendment Center and has been
endorsed by American Association of
school administrator National
Association of Elementary School
principles National Council of social
studies Nation PTA National National
School boards Association and various
religion religion organization including
Christian legal Society Council on
Islamic education and various American
Jewish Congress American Jewish
committee I would like to present this
guide to the board members I have two
copies which I will be mentioning few
things but it it is a good reading for
to bring the objectivity to this
subject this this guide begins with
citation from the US Constitution
regarding First Amendment and has
devised several
question that may be asked by the
teachers but main important objective
aspect I would like to read that the
school's approach to religion is
academic not
devotional the school strives for
student awareness of religion but does
not press for student acceptance of any
any
religion the school sponsors study about
religion and not the practice of
religion the school May expose student
to A diversity of religious view but may
not impose any particular view thank you
sir we time is
up and we have one more speaker whose
name I didn't get but sir Comm can
identify yourself and we'll give you two
minutes
[Applause]
too Michael capria
I think a lot of the message you're
hearing is off focus so go back on Focus
here and that is we're going to get
background checks on the speakers and
background check on the message we have
a process in place to serve that you
fill out an application it's a detailed
application they even want your social
security number do a background check I
don't know if these speakers that have
come before have gone through the
background check in school but we really
need to be careful who we allow to speak
and as as to the message that they're
bringing if you've been to the Middle
East as a tourist and you hear the call
to prayer it sounds lovely it's a sing
songy message that you're LED in it's
beautiful but when you hear the
translation often times they end the
call to prayer with kill the in Fel now
this is not the kind of attitude we need
to allow into the school system we need
to vet the messenger and vet the message
we have a process in place we need to
strengthen it and we're not about the
world view or teaching a world class
education we're about teaching an
American Education that's what we're
founded on that's what kept our country
strong through all these hard timeses
thank
you so board memb as I said we would
take a break at 6 my hunch is our
discussion will last more than eight
minutes okay could you talk to us about
the document that you have provided that
is the information agenda item yes um
you know I I've had the opportunity to
speak with with you miss olssen and and
others on the board as well as with um
teachers and principles and um there's
been um certainly um a number of voices
have come to the board in previous weeks
and this evening a number of voices um
who talked to us about um the issues
relating to having speakers come into
our
classrooms and um I will say I think
that that our principles and our
teachers are looking um for the
opportunity to have speakers come into
their classrooms but feel like um they
would like some guidelines I've had
specific conversations with teachers and
specific conversations with principles
about this and um and their position has
been let let us know some things that
you think um need to be reviewed as
we're looking at um guest speakers and I
have over the period of time that we've
had these discussions specifically
mentioned in in either individual
conversations with with all of you or in
the board meeting that it is very
important that we target um the the
particular sunshine state standard and
curriculum area and look at that in fact
our our original discussion specifically
identified that in many of our courses
that there are specific references to
various religious groups and so with
that in mind um
I put together the um 901a which is an
information item for the board so that
our in response to the requests that
principles had um and after discussion
with you and with um our teachers that
we would put something that would um
guide them in the determination of the
speakers that they might be interested
in having in their classroom and also
give the principles kind of a plan that
they should they should look at when
teacher comes to them and says I'm
thinking that I'd like to have a speaker
for this topic you'll note in there that
I specifically say that the district
instructional division because um I
think from a single teachers's
perspective it's important that we have
an opportunity to have a teacher say I'm
I'm doing um this particular topic is
there someone from the community and
let's take the example since many of
these are going to appear in the social
studies curriculum let's take the
example of Dr um Dennis H um Dennis is
with us tonight it would be very
feasible for a teacher to
say I'm interested in having the speaker
come in to speak to a particular item in
their curriculum and Dennis to say uh
you know I know that there's been a
speaker in another um classroom one of
our other teachers they were very
pleased with it and Dennis could then
connect them with that person now I will
say to you
I think there's some topics that
appropriately we might not have speakers
whose credentials banch our
curriculum and I think Dennis then could
say you know I don't think that that's a
good we don't have somebody that we
really feel is um has the credentials to
go in and then have a discussion um
presenting information to our students
that matches the agenda that they have
in their curriculum and in their um
Sunshine State Standards New Generation
Sunshine State Standards so 901 goes
through that talks about the
instructional division acting as a
resource for teachers that teachers will
go to principales and um provide the
name credentials in the subject matter
and the teachers will work with the
guest speakers on the
anticipation of what would be covered in
their classroom um including the teacher
desired outcomes of the presentation
aligning it to those Next Generation
sunshine state standards in the course
curriculum I do think it's important for
us to recognize that we have
professionals who are teachers in our
schools and that we have professionals
who are administrators in our schools
and that they with the use of these
guidelines can make decisions about the
appropriateness of the speakers coming
in they always have the have access to
the instructional staff who would be um
I I believe great resources and in fact
are great resources for these kinds of
questions that come up from teachers and
administrators so with all that in mind
Miss Olsen um we put this together and
um presented it for information for the
board this evening so that U we can move
forward on this I want to point out to
you and I think there were several
speakers that said that the discourse
that came from this was a positive thing
I would absolutely agree with you my
only concern my only concern is that we
have so many things that we have to
Target that are really closely related
to our educational goals not that in
fact having guest speakers in our
classrooms aren't important they are but
I think we need to accept that we've
heard from the community and accept that
there is a place for speakers in our
classrooms provide the guidelines for
our teachers and for our principles and
our teachers and then move forward with
that so with that in mind to present 901
as an information item to the
board thank you missia I'm sure a number
of board members would like to speak
those of us who are left Miss Griffin
and then miss
Valdez thank you and I've uh I've been
listening and writing and I've I've uh
not spoken out on this item in any of
the meetings that we've had and trying
to
hear the entire Community as this
discussion has Tak place and and I have
to say that um this 901a came as uh
quite a shock to me um and has kind of
muddied this
conversation and 901a and I I'm not
texting I'm not I just take notes on my
phone I have children who have taught me
how to be a little bit good with
technology but
um this is not in my opinion I'm just
going to start with this this should not
be an information item I think that this
is crossing the line into policy and
should have been a decision by this
board and initiated by this board to
have this conversation and create a
policy surrounding this so that I think
is the discussion that we need to have
around this um board at some point
because this this is Crossing into line
of policy and that's our job um we have
let teachers know that we support them
we have been very very very open about
that I know that you're saying that
there are teachers that um have have
asked for some guidance but I've heard
teachers say that they want to have some
kind of autonomy in their classroom too
and the trust of this board to be able
to bring speakers into their classroom
that they know that they have worked
with in the past and quite possibly they
could be a part of the list that the
district provides but I think that
centralizing it is um going going to
push some people out of our classrooms
that may be there right now and um as
much as I support site based management
what I'm concerned about is that our
principles will have a little bit too
much say in this process and that one
part of our community will hear a
different part or a different message
than another part of our community that
our kids in one part of this County will
not hear what children in in another
part of our County here so there's a
little bit too much in that and that's
where the Board needs to step in and set
the guidelines on so again I take it
back to that that what I said in the
beginning that this is a board decision
this is not an information item that
should be decided by you the
superintendent and all due respect I can
appreciate the difficult position that
you're in we are sitting up here too we
are being lambasted by the community so
I think that we all signed on for this
job we just need
to as some people say often put our big
girl and big boy pants on and deal with
it
um what concerns me about this
particular agenda item is in the
language speakers should be used to
educate and inform not Advocate I agree
with that this is where I start to
disagree therefore representatives of
advocacy groups should be considered
inappropriate that sounds like a policy
to
me the unintended consequences that
could come from that
are that we are going to exclude a lot
of
organizations and I just went on and
started off the top of my head writing
down uh advocacy
organizations
PTA National Association for the
advancement of colored people Florida
kid care the Hillsboro Education
Foundation Community Tampa Bay the
children's board Tampa je Jewish
Community Center and Federation the
Federation of Indian associations of
Tampa Bay ERS on patrol Advocacy Center
for persons with disabilities Center for
Family Health Hispanic American
Coalition Children's Advocacy Center
Children's Justice Center family and
school support team USF advocacy program
American art Therapy Association autism
and PDD support network Tampa Lighthouse
for the Blind achieve Tampa Bay and the
list goes oh Tampa Jewish Community
Center um Agency for persons with
disabilities best buddies these are all
advocacy groups so this is a a really
really slippery slope that we're walking
on when we say and we're therefore
excluding advocacy groups this was a
discussion that we could have had and
hammered out the details of this
so I would like
to have a conversation as a board about
this now that it's being pushed we need
to have a conversation about this
because this langu which is not okay
with
me Martin nemoyer a German pastor and
anti-communist who supported Hitler's
rise to power
said first they came for the Communists
and I did not speak out because I was
not a
communist then they came for the trade
unionist and I did not speak out because
I was not a trade
unionist then they came for the Jews and
I did not speak out because I was not a
Jew
then they came for me and there was no
one left to
speak this has regardless of how many
people stand at that Podium and say this
is not us against them this is
not about the Muslims this is this has
become a really really divisive message
in our
community I am a woman of strong faith
there is not a day that I wake up and I
thank God for what I have for my family
for my friends for the life that I have
been afforded there's not a day that I
don't go to sleep and pray for my
children's safety for my friends and
give my thanks for the life that I've be
been given and I'm going to say this
publicly because I have the microphone I
pray every day to walk in God's will I
have prayed long and hard about this and
I know that I am not supposed to live
and walk this Earth and do what I do do
in the position that I'm in and allow a
hateful message to
continue I watched the young lady stand
up here and say she was going to give a
prayer and I heard people shout out
no that they wouldn't even listen to
what she said I watched someone put
their hands over their ears and plug
their ears I watched people get up in
mass and walk out of this room because a
young woman said she was going to say a
prayer and she was Muslim
when do we learn from each other if we
don't listen to each other how can we
learn about one another if we don't open
up our ears our hearts and our
minds this has become a message of us
and them I stand with the entire
Community not one part of this community
should we have a conversation about what
groups in how we have a policy maybe we
should but I don't want to exclude
groups because of inuendo and I've read
all of the
emails I want to also caution this board
where the Great American teaching is
concerned if we start looking at
screening every single speaker that
comes into our
schools we don't do that for the Great
American teacher that's one of the
greatest days that we have in this
District that is one of the the most
Wonder days that we have to reach out
and have people from the community come
in and teach our kids about things that
they might not know and we don't do that
are we going to start there what's the
criteria where do we draw that line if
you start drawing those lines and you
have very specific criteria we are going
to miss some Diamonds in the Rough we
are not going to have speakers come into
our classes that may give our students a
lesson that they really could use um
I'm going to end my comments there